My name is Zachary Quinto.
I'm Alanis Morissette.
The inspiration for my label is the convergence of a few things.
First of all, some time that I spent in South America, which was the most connected I ever felt to the Earth.
The inspiration for my label was the idea of...
...2013 for me, personally being about the divine feminine...
...and there's no better place that the divine feminine is evidenced than in the planet.
Well, I mean the thing about saving the environment is it seems like such an impossibly huge task.
But the reality is that it's the small things that make a difference.
I choose to be socially conscious because there's no other direction to go in...
...and I like moving toward a North Star that benefits me personally...
...and my connection with other people and the planets.
And I live for connection.
I was really grateful when the opportunity presented itself to get involved...
...because I feel like you have a responsibility, and as someone that's in the public eye,...
...I'm always happy to be able to get behind the causes that I believe in...
...and I think that it's important to invite other people into a dialog...
...and invite other people to take action.
Kiehl's is incredible in that way.
I think recycling and being rewarded is very smart for us creatures who like gifting.
And we like to be celebrated, and so just to serve and then be recognized for that is really amazing.
So, at 950,000 recycled jars, that's only 50,000 away from a million.
Let's make it happen.
Recycle and be rewarded.
Are you on Twitter?
You guys on Twitter?
Yeah!
Yeah?
Follow Kiehl's on Twitter, like us on Facebook, Instagram Kiehl's...
...and recycle and be rewarded.